and now to announce the winner in the
field of film editing we have an award
winner of last year we had hoped to have
this talented gentleman with us in
Hollywood or New York but he's an
extremely busy man fortunately we were
able to catch him while boarding a plane
in Paris mmm
I hope this plane takes off on time I'm
doing Hollywood for Academy Awards oh
hey want me to present an Oscar I don't
know who the winner is nobody know I
noticed your briefcase you don't happen
to be from freshwater us do you oh okay
bye enjoy
you fellas a really tight lip now where
did that mr. price go probably looking
for mr. water results just lying around
loose I'd better find mr. price
I'm afraid Magoo goose he didn't know it
but he was sitting next to John Foster
Dulles luckily mr. price and mr.
Waterhouse have the name of the winner
for the best film editing mr. Miller if
you will please may I have the envelope
picnic Charles Nelson and William a-line
just wish to thank our fellow members of
the Academy and people that nominate us
in the first place thank you very much I
would like very much to thank mr.
Freddie Kumar the producer of the
picture mr. Joshua Logan the director
mr. Harry Cohen the president of
Columbia Pictures for taking us on this
wonderful picnic thank you